The second thing was apologizing.
I had to apologize to the people I had hurt.
Even though I had no expectations of them accepting it,
it was important to do because it was the right thing.
But I also had to apologize to myself.
The third thing was atoning.
For me, atoning meant
going back into my community
and working with at-risk youth
who were on the same path,
but also becoming at one with myself.
Through my experience of being locked up,
one of the things I discovered is this:
the majority of men and women
who are incarcerated are redeemable,
and the fact is,
90 percent of the men and women who are incarcerated
will at some point return to the community,
and we have a role in determining what kind
of men and women return to our community.
My wish today
is that we will embrace
a more empathetic approach
toward how we deal with mass incarceration,
that we will do away with
the lock-them-up-and-throw-away-the-key mentality,
because it's proven it doesn't work.
My journey is a unique journey,
but it doesn't have to be that way.
Anybody can have a transformation
if we create the space for that to happen.
So what I'm asking today
is that you envision
a world where men and women
aren't held hostage to their pasts,
where misdeeds and mistakes
don't define you for the rest of your life.
I think collectively, we can create that reality,
and I hope you do too.
Thank you.
(Applause)